retailers aren't the only businesses
suffering and Denny's in Oakland is
shutting its doors for good after 54
years due to Soaring crime so there goes
your grand slam and Walgreens is closing
down multiple locations across Boston
well that struck a nerve with Squad
congresswoman Ayan Presley who seems to
blame racial
discrimination these closures are not
arbitrary and they are not innocent they
are lifethreatening acts of racial and
economic discrimination shame on you
Walgreens wal is a multi-billion dollar
corporation that needs to put their
money where their mouth is and stop
divesting from black and brown
communities they are making this week
feel very long Greg yes Mak this week
feel long uh Thursday it is Thursday it
is Thursday Governor Nome
oblivious I think he's amazing I think
we found three words to best describe
him where's the manager America needed a
name for a male Karen and it's Gavin
Gavin is such a great name for a male
Karen I feel bad for all the Gavin out
there watching there's probably like
three or 400 but he did it I didn't cuz
he combines in that moment the sense of
entitlement and the desire to complain
right that's that's the definition of
what this person is I'm surprised he
didn't pull out his phone and start
filming the poor clerk who's essentially
given up it's not her fault it's not her
fault she's just giving up because she
can't she can't she's not allowed to do
anything because then they the insurance
companies will come down but in that
moment you saw a a an example of how
liberal leaders are wholly divorced from
the consequences of their politics
they're Upstream from the damages they
cause no one's stealing escaros from The
French Laundry they're at Target
stealing you know sh razors and
toothpaste you know all the rest of us
now have when we walk into CVS it's like
we're inside a giant vending machine
everything is locked up but that's all
because he lives Upstream from the
results of his
policies it's amazing that he's shocked
about the most publicized problem in his
State Mass theft and it's something he's
in charge of this is like a guy slicing
onions and can't figure out why he's
crying or a president who's wondering
this how does this migrant Crisis happen
when he doesn't have a border so I I and
and the fact that he's actually claiming
hey but we're the 10th best on crime how
does that help this person at her job it
was great thank you thank you Gavin
Gavin there is a move to repeal Prop 47
this is a KLA Harris uh when she was AG
that was sort of the era when the soft
on crime bill came through now there's
an effort to repeal it 89% of Voters
support changing Prop 47 and the
governor doesn't seem to be aware well I
was in Target the other day and
everything had been cleared off of the
shells by shoplifters except just stacks
of that sweater Greg's wearing nice like
the one thing they didn't steal very
good I love Nome and Gavin is a great
name for a male Caren he basically was
like don't you know who I am and it was
more of a blow to his ego that he wasn't
recognized than the Larsen that's taking
place throughout his State they are
writing laws in California that make
crime pay and he's totally unaware of it
I have a suggestion for Gavin remember
the show Undercover Boss where bosses
would dress as like regular people on
shift and then they'd figure out what
everybody thought of them he should do
that throw on one of those little
glasses with the nose in the mustache or
even blonde wig dress whatever it takes
go to the homeless shelters go to the
hood go to the restaurants and find out
the truth because that's the only way
he's going to find out now aana Presley
she represents Roxberry that area in
Massachusetts they're closing down a lot
of Walgreens predominantly black area
and a lot of the people that work at the
walg Grims predominantly black and they
are getting ransacked and they're
assaulting employees and they can't make
money there so she's saying it's racist
to avoid crime if you leave a criminal
infested area that's racist you're
supposed to stay in the crimer ridden
neighborhood and let your employees and
your customers get assaulted and lose
money cuz that's how you fight racism
being the victim ofme that would be like
Gutfeld knocking off the McDonald's day
after day after day McDonald's then
closes I can't get a double Big Mac and
I don't blame Greg I blame the
McDonald's no it's the Hamburglar right
there that's who's guilty in his outfit
uh judge the other thing is that
companies these especially retail
companies and Starbucks Etc have told
their employees you can't stop people
from stealing you can't get in the way
you have to just basically sit back and
let them and if they have gotten
involved then they get fired they get
fired yeah and it shows Gavin nome's how
egotistical he is and how unconnected he
is to workers I mean it's not just the
Karen part of it it's you know where
call your manager when he says I'm not
taking a photo you know he's angry
because she recognizes that the governor
has a role as it relates to crime and
he's not doing enough I spoke to Eric
sadell who was one of the people who's
running for da against uh the gasone and
he said to me you know it's it's
proposition 47 is bad enough and by the
way uh Gavin noome was lieutenant
governor in 2014 when that law was
passed he didn't complain about it then
but the problem with proposition 47 is
that repeat offenders get to do it over
and over and over again and no one has
addressed the fact that you got a freeb
95950 that's where the problem is it's
it's in the policy and the enforcement
but I but I do want to say that not only
does Target say you can't arrest them in
our store we did that a couple months
ago they say you can't confront them
either and one of the employees said you
know all we do is we simply document how
much they stole but I want to say
something about a Presley um I feel for
what she's saying because the minority
Community is losing the ability to have
a Lifeline of medications from
drugstores that they desperately need
and the the here's where the problem is
she doesn't understand what the root
cause is the root cause is crime and
she's got to instead of going after
corporate uh Walgreens she's got to say
we've got to fight crime stop the crime
so that employees can go in and the
minority Community can get the medicine
they want she feels that Walgreen
somehow is like a state sponsored
Corporation and that the Walgreens
should be uh charged or somehow
responsible no this is cap capitalism go
after the real problem Richard it's good
to have you back here let me just give
you the floor you can comment on
anything you want there's a lot to
comment on I actually agree with the
judge I think what the what the
congressman was trying to say is in
communities of color where you see
Health disparities very high and many of
these communities are also Health
deserts right the ideal of being able to
get your prescription drugs for senior
citizens a block away is really
important um and listen I think we do
have to figure out how we work on
addressing some of these crimes and how
we work on making sure that these
pharmacies have the other things that
they need like lotions and soaps that
are being stolen but I also think it's
important to applaud where we've been at
the beginning of the pandemic we saw a
Skyrocket in crime all across the
country what we're seeing now according
to the FBI is a decrease in crime right
violent crime has decreased 8%
Nationwide property crime has increased
decreased 6.3% in Chicago fatal
shootings have decreased 16% homicides
have decreased 133% it ran out of
victims in St Louis and Baltimore more
we've seen fewer murders in near we've
seen the fewest murders in the past
decade Detroit has had the least amount
of murders since 1966 these are good
things and we should applaud that and
now it's on what can we do to make sure
that people aren't stealing from the
Walgreens and stealing from the CVS but
it's important to applaud the policies
that are working to decrease many of
these crimes that are already happening
and in Chicago what you're seeing is
there's peace agreements between gangs
you're seeing access to more resources
in communities of color where we're
seeing high levels of crime to decrease
folks getting into crime to begin
those things are STS in the right
direction what are the policies that are
working are you talking about more
policing no well in in in some places
what you're seeing in Chicago they're
opening 24-hour Rec Center so young
people have someplace to go instead up
going to violent crime you're also
seeing them creating more resources in
schools right so you can talk to a
guidance counsel you could talk to a
social worker about what's happening in
your home instead of having to resort to
a gang or to to get help your on this
particular issue like do you blame
Walgreens for making the decision that
they're making look I I've said all
along on the this particular issue I
think we have to even when you think
about cashless bail which is one of the
issues that get us to people committing
the thefts that you see happening at
this Walgreens I think you have to make
a distinction between crimes of
desperation and people just doing stupid
things if a mom walks into a Walgreens
and steals baby formula the response is
not to arrest her resp
talking that is an argument that's so
old no but it's an argument that's still
true it could be old but it doesn't take
away these
situations I don't know a cop who would
make an arrest in that case no but there
was
time ared for was laughed at about two
years ago for saying that because
somebody was stealing bread yeah the
stealing bread Richard all right tell
the and I do just want to say that we
all love Gavin Haden he's not a Karen hi
everyone I'm Brian kilme I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now